all right we begin this hour with the
latest on the buffalo mass shooting that
the fbi director calls racially
motivated violent extremism authorities
say the 18 year old suspect who is white
explored the top friendly market in a
predominantly black community the day
before the shooting that killed 10
people and injured three others 11 of
the 13 people shot were black president
biden will be in buffalo this morning to
visit the scene of the shooting ed
o'keefe joins us with more on his trip
ed good morning nate good morning to you
the president and first lady are headed
to buffalo and plan to stop by a
memorial there at the top supermarket to
meet with victims families police and
other first responders who were there on
scene over the weekend later at a
community center he the white house says
he'll call out the quote despicable act
for what it is terrorism motivated by a
hateful and perverse ideology that tears
at the soul of our nation aides say the
president will renew his calls to pass
gun control legislation establishing
universal background checks for
purchasing firearms and a ban on
high-capacity assault weapons and
magazines but there's no sign the
closely divided house and senate can
pass that kind of bill in this midterm
election year what is clear is this is a
faster than usual trip for the president
to this kind of a crime scene and the
aftermath of a mass shooting they'd say
he wanted to make this trip early in the
week before he heads to asia later this
week tony
at o'keefe forest ed thank you very much